i'm rick everett and i'm the leader of
thanic district council
you probably know by now that fanet
currently has one of the highest covered
infection rates in the country
that's putting lives in danger and our
local nhs under pressure
it's also putting christmas at risk for
families and businesses
now of course we know that this has been
a difficult year for everyone
but now the infection rate has risen
across all age groups
and in all parts of planet and we can
reduce it
by cutting down contact with others so
for everyone's sake
we're asking you to make a special
effort to follow the government guidance
that means staying at home where
possible only leave home for food
medical reasons exercise education or
work
and work from home if you can avoid
travel unless it's essential
and do not meet with people outside your
household or bubble
and the hands-faced space message still
applies
wash your hands regularly for at least
20 seconds
wear a face covering when instructed to
do so and make space
keep at least two meters away from
people outside of your household or
bubble
it's our best chance of a merry
christmas this year
thank you